what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i will be
reacting to push ic back in blood as the
whitest girl on earth and i have the
whitest guy on earth
um with me listening to back and blood
for the first time as you guys know i've
listened to this song before but he
doesn't you haven't seen it right i have
no idea what's about to happen
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos while you're
at it go follow my instagram it's just
probably things but with a z
cherry production
[Music]
okay interpret those lyrics
oh my gosh
did you hear it again yeah yeah okay
okay
[Music]
what did you think what do you think he
said i basically said don't talk [ __ ] at
me because i
will and have come and killed people at
various establishments for talking [ __ ]
at me as well as i keep
guns on me and my security detail has
guns
yes so if you talk [ __ ] we pay it back
in blood i get it yeah yeah so
i i don't even think he missed anything
that was good let's keep going get it
back in blood we ain't mad no dog [ __ ]
know who it was doing [ __ ] just like the
haters want somebody
so on top of that they're also taught
saying that we stole from them
okay i must have missed that part but i
like the we they had 300 shots in the
car
before we like they're just like we did
that fast like yeah like we're just
rolling i want you to know that they're
they're tough like that's very
celebrated being like the tough guy the
guy that's like gonna shoot you know
that's all it's funny because it's like
the first part at least it's like well
we're defending ourselves we're
defending like our name as i was also
we're just
[Music]
[Music]
before we picked up dirt [ __ ] who
ain't got [ __ ] going go grab a glazer
get alert shots to g pose hard
you gotta know i go too far get two o's
up on this honey one of them might stand
for old blocks
so i have a question
do you have that many friends that you
could fill up a room with because i love
this [ __ ] about rap videos because like
they'll have like 50 people in the video
yeah like i came up alone from the
streets i think it's like everyone's
behind them like
oh [ __ ] word well no that's that's a
game yeah yeah yeah i just i just always
loved that though it's like
oh my god i got a i got a video you
gotta watch like
that this dude who's from chicago like
montana of 300 have you ever heard of
them we'll do it next we can do it next
[Music]
if i don't
[Music]
[Music]
i'm here for cinematography is quite
good like they got some high quality
stuff but i do wonder like
who how how they decide to put people in
the background
and like i love that just like it's like
going almost like a flight of stairs
like a really bad prom photo
the amount of people in it so they got
eleven thousand and one so hit the strip
club right
nice good good for them that's that's a
lot of singles they're not getting a
private room so i don't think
you gotta feed the homies in the back
but at this point like
okay so they had the one chorus and they
were kind of repeating yeah so it's
catchy it is catchy but like i want i
want like a rap i don't want just like
the chorus i want i want i want more
crimes my god
i want to know when that dude from the
other side of town like insulted your
mom or something like that and you and
you broke both his [ __ ] legs and like
that's that's what kanye's through the
wire was a bad turn that that's how you
broke i need something i need a little
more like i need a little more spice i i
i hear you i hear you kill your mans you
keep on talking better
get my shorty [ __ ] dubbed and they
gonna walk inside the skull hit his
little ass with that switch i bet that
switch switch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i assume that's a part of the oh is that
oh my god i'm guessing it's probably
around uh like englewood or something
like that based on the amount of like
there's the projects or something like
that yeah it's like um i don't know if
it's like a street or if it's an
apartment complex or something but it's
like a part of chicago it's a project
for sure it's a project block
i guess
you know how awkward this stuff would
look
production
like when they actually filmed it you
mean and they're all just like yeah
because like i've been in a music video
and like it's [ __ ]
it's pretty awkward except for the parts
where like
let me go back why do people carry
around cash
debit cards credit cards build your
credit
i don't understand why people like in
these music videos they just carry
around cash seems like a bad investment
i mean but what if they just took it out
for the video and then put it back in
also it could be fake money that's true
so like the music videos and we got a
money shooting gun and like oh now that
now the police are there oh yeah they've
been cutting in the chicago police like
for half this video
right so i mean they're not very good at
this thing if like the police still come
and bust them like it'd be if they had
some references to like they pay off the
cops or something like that like it's
like oh [ __ ] there's no there's no
consequences of their actions police are
showing up like
apparently there are some consequences
but well and a lot of
i think these rappers are both still
alive but a lot of the raptors i've
reacted to like they died during
yeah like the whole
well like you flash the money you flash
the jewelry and then
people know where you live yeah
really yeah it's kind of the same thing
with the people who win the lottery
right it's like
you know the smartest dude whoever won
the lottery is the guy who showed up in
a ski mask so no one knows who it is oh
right someone did that yeah because like
everyone comes out the woodwork that is
trying to call you he's trying to get
money from you whatever like if they
know that like oh [ __ ] like [ __ ]
little dirk down the street just like
came into picking a record deal or
something like that like you think
they're not gonna try to come after like
your mom like there's there's laws in
the street yeah
so are you not wise then because you put
your salary on tick tock i mean what are
they going to do they don't know where i
live
i was just wondering
i did have to stop using my instagram
because i actually do have my house
listed as a location on instagram oh
really yeah it's actually a public
now you're putting this in the video so
well no no it's not you can't find it
anymore only i actually can like add it
to my location
but yeah the wax family stayed good look
at that [ __ ]
okay pull up
all right guys let us know in the
comments if you agree with our analysis
um i think it was pretty good one to
five what do you read that song
i'm gonna give it a three three
i think like lyrically
lacking
but for bob ability for like playing the
[ __ ] in the background like yeah that's
a five
but i needed more i needed more from the
wordsmith of our generation little dirk
i just i just we had one good chorus
i'd give it a four
but i think the first time i heard it i
was so appalled that i gave it like a
two okay and now i'm used to this stuff
yeah well welcome welcome to real
tragic okay guys don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
next time